[MUSIC PLAYING]
TULSEE DOSHI: So my top
career tip for women in tech
is to surround yourself
with incredible role models.
I think one of the
best things that I've
found for myself in my career at
Google and my career at Broadly
has been learning from
and surrounding myself
with incredibly smart,
talented, motivated people.
And these are people who
lift me up, who champion me,
and who give me the opportunity
to champion and lift up others.
STEPHANIE WONG: Know how to
overcome imposter syndrome.
I face it every day, but I
have learned to really focus
on the value that I bring.
Maybe you're scared that
you're not technical enough,
or you don't fit this idea of
what someone in tech should be.
But that changes
every single day,
and we're redefining
it as women.
RACHEL BEEN: Bring
your whole self.
Don't worry about what "in
tech" is supposed to mean.
I used to be a
photographer, used
to shoot a lot of concerts
in a pit with a lot of men.
And what I learned by
navigating that scenario
I feel like it's very applicable
to my day to day life now.
RACHEL INMAN: A career tip that
I feel like has been told to me
and that I've tried to
pass along to others
is this idea of
following your curiosity.
So rather than mapping out
a perfect five year plan
or pursuing a particular
title, more so
kind of paying attention to that
little voice inside your head
that says something
is really interesting.
And kind of pursuing projects
that feed that curiosity.
DALE MARKOWITZ: When
you work in tech,
you are so lucky
for many reasons.
But one is that so many
fields and articles
can benefit from tech.
So advantage number
one is that you
can work in so many
different fields
and on so many
different problems.
And of course,
advantage number two
is that if you work
in tech because you
have this unique perspective
that's so valuable,
you're very hirable.
You can work in a lot
of different places.
ALEXANDRINA
GARCIA-VERDIN: I have
a tip on how to overcome
the "I'm not enough"
fear when applying
to your dream job.
The solution is building a
skills-based resume rather than
a timeline.
Empathy has taught me
that people need to really
quickly understand if they
should call a candidate up
or not within the first 30
seconds of reviewing a resume.
So really save your detailed
experiences for interviews
and only share a
few relevant items
that make employers curious
to learn more about you.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: My one
tip for women in tech--
just don't be afraid of
trying different technologies
and roles.
You might surprise
yourself with what you find
and what you like.
SHILPA VIR: Get comfortable
talking about your work.
So many of us have this mental
hurdle of, am I bragging?
Is it too much?
Should I be talking
about myself?
Shouldn't my work be
talking about myself?
But the reality is we are
great cheerleaders of others.
We talk at length about
their accomplishments.
And we need to be equally good
at talking about our own work.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: To value
your own perspective
and remind yourself often.
It's super easy to get
into that comparison trap,
but a difference
is not a weakness.
SIFO LUO: If you're not happy
with the current way of working
or with the culture
of our society,
and you want to be the one
to initiate the change,
my strategy is to
set your mindset
to be curious and optimistic
and stay persistent with what
you believe.
SWETHA SRINIVASAN:
Embrace changes
as they come, and be prepared
for any opportunities that
may come by.
So that you're always ready
to take on new opportunities.
ESRA KUCUKOGUZ: Do not fear.
Be brave.
Women belong in tech.
Do not let anyone make
you think otherwise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]